es ist eine protestaktion dagegen dass
fast 100 polnische gemeinden und städte
sich zu lgbt freien zonen erklärt haben
ich stelle meine fotos ins internet und
zeige genau diese gemeinden die
beschlossen haben elgeti freie zonen zu
sein
filmemacher barth ist selber schwul und
reist in die städte wo leute wie er
unerwünscht sind
diese tafeln sollen eine debatte
anstoßen die fotos lösen emotionen aus
man soll sich überlegen ob der beschluss
nötig ist
barth hat eine karte veröffentlicht die
rote zone für schwule und lesben fast
ein drittel polenz hat sich als homo
frei erklärt 5 von 16 regionen
rechtlich verbindlich sind die
beschlüsse nicht aber ein buntes polen
hier nein danke das ist eine gute idee
wir brauchen hier keine degeneration
aktuelle abnormen dies ist katholisches
christliches gebiet lgbt oder wie auch
immer du es nennst ist wildnis
was ist die nächste stufe pädophilie vor
allem der konservative südosten polens
ist homo feindlich aber auch im hippen
warschau ist so ein bild absolut
ungewöhnlich
zwei frauen die sich öffentlich an den
händen halten
emilia und agatha sind ein paar und
wollen es auch zeigen
selbst in der hauptstadt ist es nicht
leicht offen homosexuell zu leben
angst begleitet uns immer aber ich denke
dass es für frauen noch ein bisschen
einfacher ist
sicher sind wir auch nicht aber dass
sich jungs an ihren händen halten geht
in polen überhaupt nicht in berlin haben
sie geheiratet in polen gelten sie als
ledig gleiche rechte für homosexuelle
sind in noch weitere ferne gerückt
sowohl im parlament wahlkampf im herbst
als auch aktuell im
präsidentschaftswahlkampf die pis wird
einen homophoben kurs ich liebe emily
und sie ist eine frau und sie liebt mich
ich bin auch eine frau das reich umher
bürger zweiter klasse zu sein
wir müssen täglich mut beweisen jeden
tag wieder und wieder und wieder haben
wir unser coming out ich hab sogar man
erlebt dass jemand der mich beleidigt
hat seinen hund auf mich gehetzt hat
böse geguckt hat und mich der wahl mit
dreck beworfen
sie schreiend gegen homosexualität in
der stadt putzt bei einer schwulen und
lesbenparade von denen es immer mehr
gibt ein kulturkampf ist entbrannt
wenn sie sich küssen vor meinen augen
und das öffentlich zeigen stört mich das
so lange ich das nicht sehr geht es mir
entschuldigung am arsch vorbei sie
sollen es aber einfach nicht öffentlich
zeigen
polen wird nie ein tolerantes land wie
soll ich einem kind erklären dass zwei
sich küssende männer was normales sind
der 15 jährige jakob stellt sich der
parade in den weg und wurde im netz zum
helden der schwulen und lesben asse ein
gebet gegen das aus seiner sicht böse
der polizeischutz gigantisch bei den
paraden na ja christus ist für die sünde
gestorben und sie beleidigen diesen
christus
egal ob hier ein platz gebannt schaut
oder ändert sich unserer meinung nach
sollten solche exzesse verboten werden
der streit über schwulen und lesben
rechte treibt die polen um auch im
präsidentschaftswahlkampf amtsinhaber
angie du da kandidat der
regierungspartei ps spitzt bei dem thema
in den letzten tagen schafft sie
versuchen uns zu überzeugen dass das
menschen sind aber es ist einfach eine
ideologie zwei tage später mischen sich
lgbt vertreter aus protest unter du das
anhängen
der präsident legt
wir müssen diesen ideologischen
hurricane überleben so wie wir schon
viele überlebt haben in unserer
geschichte
die kirche liefert der pis regelmäßig
wahlkampfhilfe tschenstochau war der
wichtigste polnische wallfahrtsort sie
alle haben die worte des krakauer
erzbischofs im ohr der immer wieder
mobil macht gegen homo rechte auch hier
erlaubt es nicht dass das böse von
gender und lgbt polen überschwemmt und
die herzen und köpfe der polen vergällt
[Musik]
eine der vielen wallfahrten in
tschenstochau das motto dieses mal für
die familie dafür bieten sie
homosexualität hat in diesem weltbild
wenig platz homosexuelle personen
sollten ihre schwäche erkennen und das
entweder behandeln lassen oder um
heilung bitten die menschen wollen sich
einfach rechtfertigen eine sünde
rechtfertigen
das ist eine sünde nicht wahr und diese
leute zu verteidigen das ist für mich
eine sünde rechtfertigung
da geht sie die vermeintliche sünde
emilia und agata juristin und
journalistin die offen lesbisch leben
wollen und es doch nicht immer schaffen
neulich in einem geschäft weil ich sagen
meine frau hat mich geschickt was
einzukaufen aber darf ich das sagen
meine frau normalerweise würde dass
jeder so sagen und ich überlege wieder
mal haben sie es denn dann gesund nein
nein und darum geht es
man muss immer wieder diese
entscheidungen treffen eine entscheidung
ist gefallen sie wollen in polen bleiben
und für ihre rechte und für toleranz
kämpfen viele ihrer homosexuellen
freunde haben diesen kampf aufgegeben
sagen sie
und polen verlassen
[Musik]